with Jorge masvidal he's always been an
underdog his entire career he's always
just this dog they can't count out but
what does alarm me a little bit is a
huge hurry mozzle fan he said if I lose
this fight I'm done I'm retiring that
means you got one foot out the door
Gilbert Burns has two feet all the way
balls deep so for hori maswell he's had
a great run man but I hope Jorge gets it
done man I love Gilbert too but I'm just
a huge Jorge fan so it's a tough one for
him we'll see how many he has of these
left especially if you lose he's talking
about retiring I never liked that when a
fighter talks about retiring say that
after the fight don't tell us where your
mind's at going into a huge co-main
event on UFC 287 that's trouble it
always leads to trouble